[Música]
Cuántas personas se necesitan para
preparar una taza de café para muchos de
nosotros solo es caminar un poco y
vaciarlo en nuestras tazas pero este
producto básico es el resultado de un
proceso que se extiende por el mundo
cuyo costo y complejidad son mayores de
lo que se imagina todo comienza en un
lugar como el pueblo remoto de pitalito
en Colombia aquí familias de granjeros
talan los bosques locales para hacer
espacio para sembrar ordenadas filas de
cafetos estas plantas parecidas a
arbustos comenzaron a domesticarse en
Etiopía Y actualmente se cultivan en las
regiones ecuatoriales
cada arbusto está lleno de pequeñas
bayas llamadas cerezas de café algunos
frutos de la misma rama pueden madurar
en diferentes momentos por lo que es
mejor cosecharlos a mano pero cada
granja tiene su propio método para
procesar el fruto en pitalito los
cosechadores trabajan desde el amanecer
hasta el ocaso en alturas elevadas y
recolectan hasta 25 kilogramos por turno
por muy bajo salarios
los trabajadores vacían sus vallas en
molinos con agua estas máquinas separan
el grano del fruto y lo clasifican de
acuerdo a su peso los granos más pesados
y deliciosos se van al fondo del molino
se recolectan y serán llevados a
fermentar en tinas con agua durante uno
o dos días luego los trabajadores lavan
las frutas restantes y ponen a secar los
granos algunos granjeros usan máquinas
para este proceso pero en pitalito los
granos se esparcen sobre grandes
bandejas de malla durante tres semanas
los trabajadores removerán los granos
constantemente para asegurar que se
sequen uniformemente cuando los granos
de café estén secos un camión los
llevará a un molino cercano con máquinas
especiales una sopladora de aire los
clasifica nuevamente de acuerdo a su
densidad diversos tamices los separan
por tamaño y un escáner óptico los
separa por color en este punto expertos
conocidos Como catadores de café
seleccionan muestras de para tostar y
preparar en un proceso llamado cata de
café evalúan el sabor el aroma y la
sensación en Boca para determinar su
calidad
Estos expertos les dan una calificación
y los preparan para su despacho los
trabajadores llevan sacos de arpillera
con hasta 70 kilogramos de café secado y
clasificado a contenedores de acero cada
uno con capacidad de hasta 21 toneladas
métricas de café
desde puertos tropicales barcos de carga
tripulados por más de 25 personas
transportan el café alrededor del mundo
pero ningún país importa tanto café como
Estados Unidos tan solo en Nueva York se
consumen millones de tasas cada día
después del largo viaje de Colombia a
Nueva Jersey los granos de café llegan a
los clientes una vez que los
trabajadores portuarios descargan el
contenedor una flotilla de camiones
transporta el café a un depósito cercano
y después a una to aquí los granos van a
una máquina tostadora que los remueve
mientras se calientan en un fuego
generado por gas sensores monitorean el
nivel de humedad estabilidad química y
temperatura del café mientras un
ingeniero especialista en café ajusta
manualmente estos niveles Durante los 12
minutos que dura el ciclo de tostado
este proceso libera el aceite de los
granos Así que los granos sean más
fáciles de triturar y preparar y les da
un color café oscuro y un aroma
abundante después del tostado los granos
se envasan en bolsas de poco más de dos
kilogramos que son entregadas en flotas
de camionetas a cafés y tiendas por toda
la ciudad el café ahora está tan cerca
que puedes olerlo pero necesita un poco
más de ayuda para el tramo final cada
compañía de café tiene un jefe de
compras que selecciona cuidadosamente
granos de todo el mundo equipos de
logística gestionan las rutas de entrega
y Valientes baristas de toda la ciudad
sirven este cafeinado a decenas de
clientes apresurados en conjunto se
necesitan cientos de personas para hacer
llegar el café a su destino Eso sin
contar a los que se encargan de la
infraestructura necesaria para hacer
este viaje posible muchos de ellos
reciben bajos salarios y trabajan en
condiciones peligrosas y a algunos ni
siquiera se les paga Así que mientras
nos maravillamos de la red mundial
detrás de este producto asegurémonos de
no valorar el producto final más que a
la gente que lo elabora
hablando de sustancias con historias
controversiales Qué es el glutamato
monosódico o msg y es realmente malo
para usted obtenga más información con
este vídeo y no olvides suscribirte
[Música]